so oh my gosh we have an amazing weekend
[Music]
good morning everybody
I had a verbally sleep last night and
then in the early morning this morning
I'm feeling great another beautiful
sunny day here at Palm Springs pretty
productive morning started off by
message and Nina you got a message to
the wife first thing right is supporting
guys with your wife can you go away then
worked on an exciting thing that I'm
planning for my youtube channel two
exciting things so we'll see their
development can't as dropping a hint yet
but message some people on my team this
morning as well as some outside partners
that I'm working with that I'm pretty
pumped to see how things turn out
working on another potential book
talking about the top top ten rules
condensing them into the 50 top ten
rules from 50 different people let me
let you take in supply that bug you want
to see that book we're getting some
requests for that book we're taking 50
of the most popular entrepreneurs that I
have on the channel condensing them
their top ten rules into a book but now
that we're Mazon got to go to breakfast
what I was hiring somebody new we're
trying to gain salsa so it's going
through applicants and talk with Alex
about who we're going to hire but the
fun process ends out just checking in
with my team and you catching up on
things it's amazing what you can do when
you wake up early and you're going to be
productive before anybody else's away
so I'm asked why where am I going - here
wretches over there that's it another
another exciting day here climber comes
I've going to breakfast and then a
couple other sessions are happening I
managed to upgrade my ticket on American
at least the second flight from Dallas
to Toronto so I'm pretty pumped about
that last leg I'm excited get to see
Nina tomorrow get to see Timo got a
haircut
I'm pumped for that and let's go eat
hope you guys are having an amazing day
I guess when you're watching till the
weekend we have an amazing weekend and
the first one for breakfast alright well
I get the best seat and the best food
got decisions to make where am I going
to sit so breakfast got filled up see
but I forgot my badge gotta go back to
my room get my badge and then stuff
together suggestion of home
so the first session today is about how
to continue finding the love in your
channel something like that
I got here early so I can get the plug
so I can be on my laptop and plug in
charge them with devices and stuff I am
the first one here it's a day of being
the first to everything so happening you
get up a really good question guys
[Music]
their hand you have the mochi gumballs I
[Music]
miss ice cream again today charlie
everybody cruise motivate cruise mode
command will check out this channel we
got ice cream the toppings but I miss
Hyde screams I'm very far he's in the
big escape room give you my baby Mike we
might do that to the shuttle [ __ ] [ __ ]
you Zach and go check out this Kevin
Hart video on charisma with the called
seven parts and in hard 3do retailing it
if you're something like that story now
it's really good
check it out so I forget where I left
off you guys been crazy it's been
meeting up to reading operating and
going to go back to the room to chill
for a bit and then at 7:00 we're going
to do escape room Charlie apparently is
the hugest he groomed buff and they have
one here to book the time at 7:00 we're
going to meet up in the head up over
there I've got to get back and say hi
Vanina spend a little time with the wife
super important
and then tomorrow morning take off for
Toronto I'm meeting up with some a new
friend
we're going to share an uber do some
chatting he does a kid's programming how
to learn Spanish and then fly home I
managed to upgrade my ticket on the
second flight but the first one I'm
flying coach hopefully not a middle seat
let's see all right we got Nina whoo I
called Nina first but she wasn't home
she was cleaning the carpets so I hopped
in the shower I was not available I was
just cleaning this watching the carpet
the carpets are more important than me
but the carpets are clean and now she
can talk to me whoo so we're just
chatting while I pack up and I'm gonna
head off soon to get to the escape room
with Charley what do you want to say
Nina can't be good be good don't get
trapped in the escape room make it out
in time to leave at 4:45 tomorrow
morning to get to the airport and to see
me to come home and see Nina and Elise I
believe
[Music]
all right we made it escape room Palm
Springs
first challenge we'll see how we do
Charlie the escape room master see how
it is I'm not allowed to film so I'm
going to stop right here all right we
made it we won the hardest room had like
a nineteen percent success rate I did
not contribute much to the team but we
still won right we have eight minutes
left and made it our man scary very
scary fast scary and almost like decent
though but the ideas like the next let's
say you really really got in that person
that's scary
Charlie look at yourself in it Jessica
and Charlie hard cherry you want these
guys on your team
the next amazing raised power couple
right here gonna grab some dinner
Simon where we go
[Music]
should I grab a bite with the new fan am
I going to get a circle he mean buffalo
mozzarella pizza what do you got Jessica
you got food in your mouth
avocado has a trick question is
Charlie's got some salmon salmon creamy
and what Thomas has some what do you got
your people and bless all so that went
way later than expected it's almost
12:30 a.m. I got to wake up at 4:45 to
catch my flight but we had a really good
conversation I guess that's what happens
when you're getting grossed in good
conversations so I'm excited to catch a
couple hours sleep
get on the plane go home to the wife and
that's been a blast I might do this
again maybe a different conference we'll
see I was on the fence but I'm glad I
came
that's a good result so it good
conversations good people and dinner
might just do it again
we'll see have a good night everyone
good morning good morning good morning
it is morning look the same as how I
shot last night on my way to bed huh
just past five o'clock I'm going to head
to the airport come back to Toronto I'm
supposed to meet up with another fellow
youtuber basho who does a kid's Spanish
French and Chinese lessons I think
teaching kids those languages please
leave it at the same time so that we
chair noob or have a chat in the car and
head out I think there is hey Basho
you ready to go alright let's do it
[Music]
I'm in the airport I'm in the airport I
got my ticket
I'm excited from the coffee and maybe
the not asleep but getting there to all
gate yeah I love this Airport it's tiny
people are friendly giving it up quickly
and it's all open-air outdoor beautiful
something's in Palm Springs coming back
[Music]
this looks new toasted coconut I one of
those so I asked the barista
if the ice coconut cold brew was sweet
or not I didn't open need to add sugar
or not she's like it's not very good
all right it's not very good I don't
trust the police to make my drink thinks
that this drink is not very good so it
said caramel macchiato Nina would
approve the trip paper
got like 20 minutes before my flight so
head to the bathroom you can give online
some Instagram answer some emails took
your with Lena and fly home
[Music]
so looks like my flight there Tonto
American 110 got delayed to 145 to get
the key before alright so got delayed
only by like 35 minutes 25 in the [ __ ]
you know the world I'm in Dallas and
what is it about have a lot of stains in
Dallas log deal but the books in dollars
though people I know are in Dallas
agents in Dallas I got to make a stop in
downloads Egyptian dollars dealer to
come by spend longer than two and a half
hours let me know
let's get up on my feet and then let me
even though they're going to be late
[Music]
I'm pretty sure you're going to get
someone on the plane or in about 45
minutes let us I can settle up and get
the old tail community
and I bet it was green tail smoothie for
McDonald's or Pizza like you know why
they'd have enough junk this weekend
now get back to being healthy not that
this was insanely helping but rather
McDonough
[Music]
all right I landed see some flights a
little bit late to get off and got put
in a circle before landing here don't
get the upgrade and going to meet me
outside
go get even relax get to sleep tonight
after that flowers and that's it thank
you guys long enough
thank you guys for joining me let me
know what you think let me know where I
should go next into conferences I want
em else to comfortable which strategies
you learn from conferences put the
comments below to find out hope you guys
have a great weekend believe